[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt einen erdbeerkuchen
erdbeertorte denn die etwa zeit muss
natürlich zelebriert werden und ich
werde jetzt einen mandelkuchen machen so
eine mandel baiser masse darüber eine
erdbeer masse und darüber bis e die
torte ich hab davon geträumt ich sag's
euch da freue ich mich schon die ganze
woche drauf deswegen starten wir auch
direkt die zutaten sind echt
überschaubar da müsst ihr gar nicht so
viele nehmen ihr nehmt dafür drei eiweiß
eine prise salz 150 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt und 180 km mandeln jetzt
gebt ihr einfach zuerst das eiweiß mit
dem salz in eine rührschüssel
dann schlagt ihr das eiweiß steif und
rührt den zucker langsam ein und rührt
dann etwa fünf bis zehn minuten bis sich
der zucker etwas aufgelöst hat ich werde
dann schon mal in der zwischenzeit auf
die mandeln finalen
[Musik]
da ist dürfen ellerhoop das sage ich
euch denn das ist ja nicht mehr lustig
sondern cremig und ich will natürlich
bis zum schluss hier alles aus garbsen
so solltet ihr mal setzt aussehen schön
glänzend
schmeckt dann am ende wie so
manche makronen als kuchen
und vor allem ist die torte glutenfreien
das auch gut dann gehe ich jetzt hier
vanille extrakt rhein
und die gemahlenen mandeln und die
werden kurz untergehoben
[Musik]
ich habe ich den ofen schon auf 160 grad
ober unterhitze eingestellt hier habe
ich einen bug ring 20 cm im durchmesser
und natürlich die masse rein und
verteilt so schön
[Musik]
und dann wird der kuchen direkte backen
und sobald es fertig ist geht es direkt
weiter mit der täglich
[Musik]
für die extrem verwende ich 200 gramm
erdbeeren 100 km h den saft einer halben
zitrone etwas tonka passte
450 gramm zucker zwei teelöffel stärke
eine tüte platine oder ag 600 gramm
frischkäse und etwas seiner partei gebe
ich zuerst die erdbeeren und himbeeren
in einem topf das wird jetzt so eine art
erdbeer himberg hört also wieso einen
lemon gehört nur eben mit erdbeeren und
himbeeren und
dann kommt der zitronensaft statt so
dass schneide ich
immer ganz gern den zepter da weckt
natürlich besser ausgepresst
[Musik]
dann kommt hier die tonga passte dazu
ja und auch da zucker
und gerne noch die stärke
und jetzt berät er die zutaten gerne
miteinander
[Musik]
statt immer nur das nicht rausspringen
ich will mich sowieso ein formel 1
fahrer
jetzt habe ich hier diese schöne
pürierte masse da kommt jetzt die
platine dazu besitzt praktisch schon
lemon gehört aber ich möchte auch dass
es später schön fest wird für die torte
deswegen bleibt magazine oder ihr nehmt
agger aus der tüte einfach mit dazu
geben jetzt und dann muss es wirklich
mindestens zwei minuten lang sprudelnd
kochen alternativ falls er zum beispiel
mit gelatine arbeiten wollt dann kocht
ihr jetzt diese masse liegt sie schön
ein könnt so lange gelatine auflösen in
wasser und dann nehmt ihr aber die masse
vom herunter und rührt dann die gelatine
in die heistmer sein statine darf
nämlich nicht kochen da muss man einfach
darauf achten das sage ich auch immer
gerne dazu weil es dann doch immer
wieder falsch gemacht wird agamus kochen
zwei minuten lang gelatine darf niemals
kochen das muss man sich merken
vielleicht noch so zum unterschied also
eigentlich bin ich ja schon immer fan
von aranka dass man einfach die
pflanzliche variante nimmt gelatin hat
aber auch einen vorteil man muss sagen
ich nehme es nicht so gerne es gibt ja
hinterrad hier habe ich das trotzdem
nicht so gerne weil ich da einfach immer
denkt da muss eigentlich nichts
tierisches in so einer torte sein aber
es hat den vorteil dass bei statine die
taten so ein bisschen muss ähnlicher
werden und aa kk ist schon so ein
bisschen sehr ähnlicher aber ich finde
da schmeckt trotzdem gut und ich finde
engagement halt auch nicht raus das ist
wirklich komplett geschmacksneutral
[Musik]
sobald die masse kocht dann wirklich
zwei minuten lang sprudelnd kochen
lassen ich nehme mir da tatsächlich
immer hat die uhr zu hilfe am herd
stellt die rein und dann geht er hat
auch automatisch auf da muss ich nicht
auf die uhr achten
[Musik]
fertig
dann streicht ihr die masse gerne durch
ein feines haar sieht ich nehme da ganz
gerne das fleißige lieschen dafür
gleich schön durch passieren und dann
entferne ich sozusagen die erdberg kerne
und wenn sich zum beispiel doch
klümpchen gebildet haben durch stärke
oder dann verschwinden die auch dann
habe ich gleich schöne schein passierte
masse
[Musik]
schön schön
die masse lasse ich jetzt hier kurz
stehen die dahw lauwarm abkühlen aber
nicht zu lange stehen lassen agatha wird
nämlich schneller fest als scharlatane
und dann kann ich schon mal den
frischkäse in einer großen schüssel mit
seiner tat etwas verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt den frischkäse einfach schon mal
schön verrühren und seiner partner zu
geben
[Musik]
jetzt ist wichtig dass ihr nicht die
warme masse in die kalte gibt dann
geräte so ein bisschen und dann gibt's
so kleine gelatine oder aka aka wie sage
ich also kleine die heißen dass sowieso
krümelchen in das wolle man hat ja so
gummiartig deswegen gebt ihr immer die
kalte master nicht immer als ich habe
jetzt auch schon mehr tore gemacht das
kommt aufs rezept an aber normalerweise
macht man so immer ein bisschen kalte
masse in die wabe rühren damit sich die
temperaturen leicht
mit das nehme dann beim nächsten rezept
sagt ja selber dem haus aber anders
gemacht
es kommt immer manchmal darauf an aber
hier ist die jetzt frischkäse in die
wache
[Musik]
dann schön hier den rest dazugeben und
kurz einrühren
jetzt so ein richtiger selima alles aus
der großen schüssel schön in die kleine
so rein gekratzt leben am limit
den rest hebe ich jetzt so noch kurz
unter und dann habt ihr hier den
abgekühlten mandl weserbogen
und wenn die am rand so ein bisschen was
hoch geht ihr drückt sie einfach mit den
händen runter
dass der boden schöneben ist dann sieht
es nämlich später gut aus jetzt kommt da
dem masse einfach drauf wird glatt
gestrichen und die torte wandert erst
meinen kühlschrank
[Musik]
da kommt die torte den kühlschrank ich
stecke jetzt gleich noch mit einem
torten rad ab damit nichts drankommt
die torte ist jetzt schon seit vier
stunden im kühlschrank und ist perfekt
durch gekühlt ich hole sie auch gleich
raus werde jetzt aber schon mal die
baiser masse zu bereiten natürlich
können sie die torte auch so lasse mit
erdbeeren dekoriert servieren aber bc
ist einfach etwas was ich sehr liebe und
vor allem was jetzt auch gut sortierte
passt vielleicht auch eine kleine info
falls er die torte wirklich glutenfrei
zubereiten wollte sollte doch verachten
das saunabad noten beinhaltet das heißt
da einfach den salat weglassen und am
besten einfach mehr ag bzw blatt
gelatine oder platine verwenden ich
mache jetzt hier die b&c masse das ist
eine pc masse die gleich erhitzt werden
muss damit einfach auf salmonellen
abgetötet werden weil sie eben nicht
mehr in den backofen kommt ist er hier
doch jetzt praktisch so ein moped auf
der torte und dafür mache ich nicht
masse aus drei eiweiß einer prise salz
150 gramm zucker und vanille extrakt ich
gebe jetzt das eiweiß mit salz und
zucker in einen topf und entweder könnte
jetzt über dem wasserbad arbeiten also
einen topf geben und wasser drin eine
schüssel drüber und das ganze schön zehn
minuten lang erwärmen und praktisch über
dem wasserbad gut verrühren da wird dann
das eiweiß schön pasteurisiert heißt es
eben und dort solltet ihr es eben zehn
minuten lang erwärmen oder verwendet
einfach die kennwort mit koch funktion
könnte dabei 70 grad einfach einstellen
so werde ich jetzt machen weil es mir
eben die zeit spart und einfach dem
schneebesen verrühren und später nach
den zehn minuten die hitze ausschalten
oder wenn ihr auf dem kochtopf dem
kochtopf auf dem herd kocht einfach den
topf unternehmen und praktisch kalt
rühren das heißt dieser vorgang dauert
jetzt so ungefähr zehn minuten warm
schlagen und dann noch mal ungefähr 10
15 minuten kalt rühren
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier meine baiser masse
ich glaube ich las tatsächlich wandel
extrakt weg denn ich will dass sie
perfekt weiß bleibt und ich hab ja auch
ein elektro in der torte ich hatte
tatsächlich nach dem backen des
mantelbogens den abkühlen lassen und
dann mit tortenring messer schon gelöst
das heißt normalerweise müsste das jetzt
so perfekt
hier habe ich jetzt die baiser masse ich
lebte sehr einfach
so einige dinge die ich in der küche
liebe aber pc gehört definitiv dazu es
ist einfach immer schön
wie sehr passt zur schokolade ohne zu
früchten
also
ich finde deswegen braucht da gar nicht
so viel deko um diese torte ich werde
das jetzt gleich noch flambieren müsst
ihr aber gar nicht denn ich habe die b
semester schon pasteurisiert könnt ihr
auch einfach so schneeweiß lassen wie
ihr wollt
ein bisserl zuspitzen ziehen
klar ist es schön
ich habe jetzt noch ein paar erdbeeren
geschnitten dieser wir ich dann einfach
dazu da haben wir noch was schönes
fruchtiges
so gefällt mir
[Musik]
wunderschön
da setzt sich jetzt
wird
die torte probieren
die szene
[Musik]
heute darf jetzt eine freundin von mir
probieren die er glaube ich im
youtube-video noch nicht gesehen habt
die selmer aber auf instagram
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja darf schreibt probieren also ich habe
eine erdbeertorte backen ohne mehl mit
baiser und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob
sie dir schmeckt
ja bisher
tatsächlich könnte ich sie mit allem
kombinieren
der erste schritt ist immer schwierig
weil es salopp geklebt
und haben uns meine erdball habe ich
gerade da
darf jetzt noch probieren weg als erstes
mit bussen ich hoffe es schmeckt nicht
zu süß
tisch von cremig gern einmal
richtig super lecker dem wünsch mir zum
geburtstag ja sehr schön ich finden auch
gut und tatsächlich kann man diesen
kuchen auch außerhalb der erdbeerzeit
machen mit gefrorenen erdbeeren weil sie
sowieso verkauft wird da hat mir auch
ein schönes aroma und das was man am
ende so schmeckt das tonkabohne
erdbeer himbeer
jetzt wurde sagte ich finde es hat man
immer so später noch mal so ein aroma
der fall schön da mag die käsekuchen
machte auch sehr muss ich sagen zu einer
kiste mit frischkäse tatsächlich also
kein quark eine sonnenuhr frischkäse und
das ganze schön verkocht wie so ein land
gehört schöne kombis ganz toll das
selber schmeckt die trotte ich bin zwar
richtig lecker und vor allem finde ich
sehr schön ich liebe es einfach mit pc
zu arbeiten
und falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt dann schaut gerne in meiner app
vorbei oder auf see ließ - blog.de finde
ich euch viel spaß gemacht
bis zum nächsten mal
und ich nehme das könnte
[Musik]